un rassemblement à paris en soutien la
communauté colombienne quelques milliers
de personnes se sont retrouvés cet après
midi place de la république
une mobilisation conséquente pour
dénoncer la répression policière sur les
manifestants en colombie depuis deux
semaines le pays est secoué par des
manifestations contre le gouvernement de
droite du président et d'indiquer les
violences ont fait au moins 26 morts et
des centaines de blessés
réactions à paris alors en ce moment un
colombie la situation est très grave il
se trouve qu'en fait le peuple se fait
directement massacrés par le
gouvernement et dont nous sommes en
soutien ici pour le vab les colombiens
et justement pour toutes ces personnes
qui se font tuer par le pouvoir par la
police et par le gouvernement qui est
totalement corrompu et qui m'est fait
rien fait pour cours pour sauver le
peuple et pour améliorer la situation du
peuple
c'est vraiment un gouvernement de
paramilitaires qui est depuis des années
80 mais joey ouellet a vraiment explosé
et que franchement ils ont kidnappé la
colombie en plus de ça après les
convives il ya eu une crise qui a
vraiment augmenté la pauvreté en
colombie et le gouvernement a essayé de
solutionner ces crises parmi 200 porcs
plus portes à tous la consommation des
produits qu'on concentre tous les jours
comme les tomates des oignons la demande
au gouvernement français
c'est de réagir tout simplement parce
qu'elle est peuple colombien il en
colère il en colère parce qu'il n'a pas
mais le gouvernement français
aujourd'hui il pu faire un appel arrêtez
de tuer les personnes arrêtées la durée
la population